you did see a game number one again is
combine hard point we're going to be
looking forward to Game two
snd search-and-destroy a staple of the
Call of Duty eSports community it is
going to be played on hunted now hunted
is a big game hunting lodge it's
situated beneath the waterfall in the
lush mountains of Ethiopia where rugged
terrain opens up the long sight lines in
a stealthy underwater pathway so so
we've seen some interesting stuff using
log on or pathway in this and you're
going to definitely see it in this match
I mean players going cross map under the
water just jumping out onto the pub side
able the surprise players planning or
defusing it's awesome to watch you have
to check so many areas it's not going to
be really predictable search-and-destroy
and I think you know the bands protects
is gonna be huge in this know what
changes from game wow that's beautiful
water there game oh it's beautiful water
it looks great
you probably split rate vacation town
yeah it's a hunting lodge you wouldn't
want to vacation there but gonna get
into bands and protect voting here see
what Merkin sensor do right off the RIP
alright time to get going now we are
going to see again the m8 gonna be bad
it's gonna be sensor taking it off the
map here and again these players I know
we're just starting to go live here with
out with our gameplay but they've been
feeling each other out here for a little
bit of time and then you're gonna see
Merc he's gonna protect vision polls so
bish tell me why is the surrounding area
and tax location of all enemies within
the range for a period of time so we saw
Tommy do some amazing things for that
gotaga he's gonna protect the mana war
for buzz oh that's puzzles go to gun you
know CT he's gonna ban the UAV doesn't
want somebody on the opposing team you
really just pick up some easy kills get
that streak right off the RIP so see
what flexi and kv decide to do with
their bans or effects that's a common
wall Pete mister objective making sure
the UAV not going to be involved up next
up flex going to be taking out six cents
we've still got three bands and protects
left and you saw the work getting done
with you and I layer and hardly I think
about how much more affected by D&D
right before Tommy could get to protect
akivi removes it from the game so that's
actually really big Tommy he's gonna
protect Lich which we saw some amazing
stuff out of sensor earlier today I mean
he made one of the craziest place I've
ever seen buzz oh he's gonna remove c4
from the game now we're gonna have that
specialist draft maven which specialists
do you expect to see in this one
honestly we talked about glitch how
amazing that has been the plays that
we've seen players able to come up with
I typically would say Ness Indian eyelid
but we also obviously we saw that ban so
not gonna really see that come to as
much effect now reject I know we've
talked about it a bit tell me why it's
so popular why I feel like that's gonna
be one we're gonna be seeing a lot of
the game types alway it's just a great
ability to have I mean you're able to
recover from Death Note that smoke area
pumps up you're able to get out and then
give yourself another chance at ITP is
gonna go with the psychosis that could
be in toward defense right you could
throw it out on defense get some shots
see the mini-map and then you're able to
your pinpoint where that player is
gotaga going with the vision pulse I
would be I was just going to say I'd
have been surprised if Tommy didn't go
with vision pulse there and that's a
smart play by Tommy we'll take that one
yeah the the vision pulse I mean we saw
it was at Tommy I think yesterday or
earlier today actually mean an amazing
play with it you're getting that vision
able to go huge and then tell what while
we're loading into the game here while
they're headed into classes kind of walk
me through what sensor did the other day
with glitch it was one of the coolest
things I was screaming its snd on hunted
he's in the middle of map he has a
specialist ability there's a player
using Reaper coming around the corner
knows where sensor is sensor glitches as
he gets hit he goes to a building where
he previously was and then the guy with
Reaper he just looked like it was they
came in the corner and he looked and
he's like he's not there and sensor was
able to pick up the kill I think it
would decide the map so it was perfect
you just saw the other you can see
sensors point of view or the other
player just like head on a swivel is
like where where where did he go
if shots come in from behind he gets
clean up I think it was like a 1v1
situation tears were going nuts it was
such a crazy play but you see how
different the specialist trap and the
bands and protects works from game mode
the game mode all right I've got an snd
it's gonna be completely different than
what you would use in a respawn game
mode so just awesome to see that type of
diversity and Call of Duty it's gonna
take a really good team leader right
somebody who does the study work on an
opponent knows what they like to use and
then it's gonna create you know players
to be more versatile right I mean if
everyone knows you're gonna be good with
a gun they're gonna try and ban it right
away and then it comes to the point well
you know do you want to waste one of
your bands or protects on it yep is it
worth it for your touch maybe you have
another assault rifle that you're just
as good at or maybe you can switch over
to an SMG because there's an assault
rifle on your teammates is better at so
for team play and just strategy just add
so much death to
game and just think about I think back
to Black Ops 2 we're talking S&D streaks
that much more well I don't say that
much more important but the number of
times you get them compared to a respawn
make them that much more vital you know
you may only get one shot at using some
of these things now that you have the
specialist to go with it there's so much
of it I don't like this is baiting game
you know when are they going to use it
what is it up theirs they're so much
more data and use it lose the round that
is HUGE oh yeah you need to win the
round you use those because it's huge
for your team we're gonna jump right
into the game it seems like murk busting
out the sniper rifle here I mean we have
to start with the bars right yeah I mean
when somebody's rockin the sniper rifle
gotta show that action is he's got
rejects got a pistol sidearm was he
running for perks got overclocked past
hands primary gunfighter as well so he's
gonna have three attachments they're
dead silence back you need it in snd
with the footsteps and see what he's
gonna do off the rip he's gonna go to
this left side I saw them doing this
earlier even watch this they're gonna
cover for Tommy as Tommy it's gonna try
and run on the wall on the side of that
bridge and get to the opposing side of
the map caches go tog off guard there
and that's incredible great stuff there
they're worried about the sniper of
Merck and then a lot of times where
we've seen engagements here as he could
he get a second no gonna get a tag dog
hitmarkers for days a lot of these
pushes a lot of the engagements has been
coming kind of by that there's a area up
here where ki he was cover he was
covering the b-bomb site as well see
it's gonna be flex who would its scored
here and pushes but everyone's rotating
back they know the bombs here Merck set
up he's got the pistol out you know he's
not the best position because he had
that sniper for this particular spot I
hurt sorry cane TV with the slavery will
see you next round I'll see you later kV
it's gonna be 3 V 2 and he's gonna get a
hit marker with the sniper rifle now
gonna like to push with that pistol he's
gonna get taken out from behind so it's
gonna be buzzed up last one alive here
for Team kV it's gonna be a round one
tagged up in team TP they take Game one
they're looking strong here at Game two
and you gotta love that push by Merkin
Tommy had them on the lower side of the
mini-map Merck covering with that sniper
you called it perfectly Tommy's gonna
use this wall run get up close and
personal picks up the kill anything also
really stood out for you in that round
other than Merck ripping off the pace of
for keeping nah welcome to Germany
without house amazing shot right there
by Merck C team TP gonna get that first
round
I'm gonna jump over the offensive side
watching gotaga here I'm actually go to
hkey because he's gonna be your bomb
carrier trying get aggressive on this
b-side he's gonna be tossing great in
forward able to get a hitmarker back him
up let's see if he tries to get pushed
forward go for a quick plan here well
it's so dangerous to go towards this B's
site right because there's a player on
the defensive and over at a they can
actually jump into that water get cross
map so fast jump up right up a
surprising see Tommy on the left-hand
side with TP gonna gain some support
fire gonna be able to take out gotaga
there and you see the man-of-war in the
hands of flex and he's going underwater
wrong he's got that glitch to go as well
they've got the bomb planted can he make
this sneaky play he's getting up here
you see it go use the hip fire coming in
and gonna be able to clean up the kill
that's all four down that's gonna be a
defuse coming in and it looks like he's
actually gonna leave it up to Tommy I
believe yep yeah Tommy probably gonna
get oh look how close he is he actually
gets his specialist going in the next
round so that is huge
so you see flexy has it Tommy has it he
drops at their form so do they use it to
go up three Oh do they save it take case
the other team mates to come back that's
where the strategy comes in with the
specialist abilities
alright so wasted we are two rounds in
your senior round any killcam here
getting ready to go into round 3 you see
team TP already out to a 200 at Vantage
I believe just due to time were to be
playing this I believe first before so
were you halfway
his team team TPA let's go over I want
to start off with the bomb carrier TP is
three enough and he's got his psychosis
I think we stay on with TP and
absolutely use it this round this will
be a good round to user right they can
go towards be maybe throws it around
this corner exactly what I was thinking
so now see he's gonna see the shots come
in at the B bombs like that player is
gonna fall back and it's gonna look out
passive that player how he's terrified
right side does it does it work as well
steep no like that drops out at the
perfect time it will take him out we go
cross went with flexi he's actually
pretty weak has that glitch ability last
one alive and one be three I would not
be surprised he tries to use it this
round tries to clutch the situation no
you're already up to oh maybe if you say
like get one so he gets when he's got
the RC car doesn't it like to use it now
maiden I I'd like to see him tries it a
1 B 2 you're on the stream can you be
mr. cluster for overnight
that gunfight can't control the sprite
gonna lose that one to buzz Oh buzz oh
he's been winning a majority of his
one-on-one gun fights you saw another
reason why they're just absolutely
dismantling flex they're able to get on
the board here and it just I had so many
different you know questions to your
game right now it's not only anymore you
know all right which bombs are we going
what class we gonna run it's like okay
now we have streaks now we have
specialist abilities like well when are
we gonna run them you know do you use
them together do you use like a collage
to come out of the corner then the
reaper ability you know to throw those
drugs out there really try and confuse
the opposing team
all right let's hop off with Doug sensor
Martin voted most likely to be in a
reality show in 2016 we'll see if he can
come up with some big plays you see he
does have his specialists ready yeah and
it just seems like they're just trying
to get a thing here they have one player
cross at Merck I shot given a bacon down
by a sensor though but Merck was able to
get to this round is gonna be a 2v2
flex and TP burst sensor and buzz Oh CT
going on that long flanked the RC mark
is out see if he's able to pick one up
he's trying to get close not him he goes
for a whirl right there it's gonna be
flexed the only one alive as tepees
taken out by sensor now we saw flex
trying to attempt a 1v3 last round able
to narrow down to one versus two before
he lost that gunfight with Buzzle let's
see if he can do it here he's got sensor
and his arch nemesis buzz Oh to deal
with right now
well he didn't use his ability in the
last situation does he use it now or
does he let the game potentially get to
a two - he's gonna pick up one on bomb
center right around the corner since are
able to win the gunfight going big right
there for Team keavy it's gonna be all
tied up at - yeah and this is tied up to
2 because team keep you winning those
one-on-one gunfights when it come down
comes out - you saw puzzle win one you
saw sensor winning it here accurate
shots coming in to close it out they tie
it up to two so first the four maven
ranked first really pivotal round for a
team to win you expect them to use you
know if they have a streak if they have
a specialist ability but this is where
you think the round would do min to play
well let's stay with TP then he has it
up he's gonna have the bomb and actually
I'm sorry
was going for a switch over to TV he's
gonna have the bomb wash a stay with
Fleck some pcs he hasn't used it yet
he's held onto it for several rounds now
is this something you use earlier you
wait for that one-on-one maybe 2v1
situation me know that glitch ability
you want to use it when you feel like
you're going to die in that gunfight
it's gonna come directly to the right
hand side a buzzer label pick him up so
huge first blood right there he's gonna
get shot from behind didn't have an
opportunity to use his ability I was
wondering as soon as I saw a player
flanking on the mini-map I was like is
he gonna try this answer has his as well
so he gets pushed by the second player
maybe he decides to use it TP too fast
though out of the water that was such a
great face vine team TP you see Merc
he's gonna get taken now use his entry
Jack ability comeback like that is a
huge play right there yeah if he wins
this one be two after the reject that
would be so sick he's got the sigh he's
trying to push up his play right to his
left can he get the kill pistol the
hipfire not going to get it done they'll
be able to get the defuse that's going
to be TV on it and that was what a 200
lead 14 TV held back the the backgrounds
here for team keep either one away from
closer today you know flexi doesn't use
his glitch ability Merc burns his right
there you know Burns has read Jack now
team chief he doesn't really have much
to work with I believe Center still has
his specialist abilities so if they want
to they can really kind of go for the
kill this round and put this game away
well that's what you're taught it's
we're talking earlier kind of you know
you get that lead do you want to use
them early and just create automate just
know all this close it out they decide
not I decide to save these clutch moment
different teams your mind sense on when
to use these things there won't be a
right way there won't be a wrong way
just kind of player preference you see
Buzzo has that Reaper Billy gonna bust a
sniper rifle out and this is gonna be
great because he's gonna be able to just
throw those drones out there and then
Jaffe like poke out with the sniper
rifle pick one player off will see if
he's gonna be able to get eyes on anyone
I believe across the way is gonna be
murkiest hasn't got a line of setup and
yet it's actually a merc that's gonna be
using the wall con he's gonna try and
get up comes in the window how to win
the gunfight he's gonna lose that one
you gotta love the bit of parkour
they're coming out of work trying to get
bored it's gonna be sensor able to win
the gunfight they have a four verse to
advantage right now if they can win this
round they'll be able to take game
number two watching sensor he's getting
forward I'm gonna switch over to key V
the bomb carry he needs sensor to get
them but he's gotta know he's about as
well so key B's gosh drinks has a
special
his team is in a much better spot to win
this game look how sneaky TP is right
now mavin don't want to spoil it to 4v1
oh he's going for the ninja defuse right
there gets taken out you gotta try it
right yeah you got you're at you're in
the one before TP tries to sneak the
ninja in unfortunately TV setup too
smart ready to close it out yeah the
psychosis ability maybe would have been
able throw that out on Bob get one
player to just run over there just or
maybe shoot at it catch somebody off
guard might have been the time to use it
right there but the one before really
nothing you can do about it